Make sure that your dreams are yours.
Make sure that you are not pursuing the dreams...
...that somebody thinks you should have...
...because dreams take a lot of work and a lot of support.
You'll be more inspired to go after them if they're really really yours.
The things that challenge you the most in life...
...are probably gonna be the things that you look back on...
...and are so grateful for because they made you better.
So, the things that challenge you, try to be grateful for them...
...and try to imagine how they have been put in your life specifically to help you.
Take a deep breath, know that nothing is forever.
If people are pressuring you to excel,...
...it's probably because they really care about you.
But just do your best. That's all that matters.
That will lead you where you are supposed to go,...
...if you really are doing your best.